hey guys Ryan right here and Murray yep
doing another video with my neighbor the
woman who's not involved with film at
all who better to put in front of the
camera and someone who has no interest
with doing anything with the camera
freaks me out the battery's about to die
but we're gonna watch the trailer for
sex tape hot chick
Michelle Fernandes yeah Michelle fern
has recommended this to me and I was
like you're hot gonna listen to your
opinion on this gonna watch this trailer
it starts Jason Segel do you know that
it's from How I Met Your Mother
yes and like that [ __ ] jack [ __ ] with
him yes sir marshal globulin and Cameron
Diaz from the mask but Jim Carrey ever
since then her career hasn't been too
what has she done yes so we're gonna
watch this trailer
hopefully it's funny do you remember the
first time inside do you remember the
last time I may be late for my thing it
looks great
don't even think about it yes sir you
lost a lot of weight I was having sex
that's a great idea this is your best
idea ever
let me erase that video no eraser don't
forget okay just when they thought the
relationship was good
you really
oh [ __ ] scary you know the cloud instead
of erasing the video like you said she
would
our sex taken to all the iPads we gave
out of gifts technically yes
my mom Bobby my boss in the mail Minh
the mailman it was Christmas every one
of those iPads right now and you can't
get it down from the class nobody
understands the clock have some fun
who has sex for three hours
Wow the movie Lincoln you did the full
Lincoln I'm gonna distract my box for
the [ __ ] iPad Siri how do you perform
CPR on a dog distracting him you're
distracting him with cocaine with
Scarface wow dude oh they both look
really good good actually
thanks he's lost a ton of weight and she
looks great for her age was she like 69
yeah yeah that looks really funny that's
a great plot in directed by the person
from Bad Teacher mm-hmm no you don't
like that movie
I just you know actually I was okay oh
good you have a strong opinion about the
movie and now you're ashamed anytime you
see cut that out
Ryan's gonna give it your dick yeah oh
yeah that looks really funny it's a
great concept and look yeah what more
can you say it's gonna be hilarious
hopefully it's just a trailer crawling
over the master on the best parts she
hate that when a comedy does that right
there might have happened here that
might have happened here but hopefully
it's better than the trailer would like
friends who give out iPads as gifts to
people you know if I did a sex tape I
would totally want people to watch it
you wouldn't look at it if I was like
Murray there's a sex tape I didn't I
mean I'm sure you would show it to me
like I'd probably yeah
force you to watch it the only reason I
came over here is because Ryan called me
and told me we were gonna watch a sex
tape this is not exactly what she added
my yeah I did oh I love do you think I
could get into porn um I and you might
have to do gay for pay oh well you gotta
make sacrifices along the way any gay
subscribers out there
lemon no we can make something together
on the topic of subscribers if your
needle
scribe yeah and then you know put in a
trailer request or something I all the
trailers i watch are based off what they
recommend to me the only time I catch a
new trip
this never happens I don't catch new
trailers in the theater anymore because
I've already seen it ok so I've never
like oh this is interesting
remember this trailer yeah but oh man
that's this movie I can't wait to watch
it that time
Murray Neil time it is it's time to
shout out she knows it ha
Nathan Rojas called dibs [ __ ]
you've got them dibs [ __ ] yeah so BAM
Rojas that's like a name out of [ __ ]
like Game of Thrones or some [ __ ] mark
from row of Games birdie-bird skate yeah
yo dude you got a cool icon and 64
controller remember n64 do I remember
and 64 DS Super Mario I don't remember
much else from before I was like deal
before the Gamecube oh yeah I came back
in Jordan Walters this guy he's be
flattered the [ __ ] out of me he put me
in this category Jeremy John's Chris
stuckman the schmoes knows and that was
like a major [ __ ] compliment I was
like dude you made my night so thank you
man
thank you I want to end this on a
sincere note sincerity genuineness love
addiction porn leave Murray so I can
watch my addiction of bored